welcome to this video this will be short
when i'll just play a couple of bloods
games the idea of this video is mostly
to test a new audio setup I changed some
some setup and i hope the problems of
this beeping noise and other background
noises is solved now and I've actually
tried to get a game here three minute
game no success let's try some other
time controls game starting all right I
get a five minute game against
grandmaster roses here I'm not coach i
think is originally from latvia no he's
got a Czech Republic flag maybe he's
working there's a coach or something
don't know him now he's even playing a
move all right let's play you 45 check
out them rue la paz exchange variation
yeah I play a couple of sight lines
against the exchange mostly to UM get
some more interesting game going
compared to main on main lines of the
exchange all right be three this
interesting is trying to put some quick
pressure on e5 and I'm really not sure
that I want to play f6 after all that
probably I want to play Bishop f6 but
the Bishop b2 I'm not quite sure how to
protect me five Queenie seven looks
rather unnatural not sure that I like it
maybe I can play sugar g4 let me now f6
so that after d for now it cannot take
with the night here I actually could
take on f3 to damages power structure
but I'm very weak on the light squares
I'm not sure if this is a good idea I
could simply take of course the Sun
probably isn't a very dangerous for me
this end game but f6 is some rather
unconvincing structure not sure if this
is a good idea all right now I want to
get the light to f7 and then Bishop d6
maybe you should be five if possible ok
let's um I get your Bishop d6 now ok you
can play a 5 which is an idea but you
know so this but this should be ok I
could have played Bishop f4 actually
this this would have been better maybe
okay but I don't slam don't really think
that I should have any particular
problems here maybe I could have played
95 earlier the Sun possibly was a more
exact more accurate looks like still
with some further exchanges I should be
should be fine I have the idea of night
b-52 c3 on somewhere c3 probably so I'm
not sure that he can avoid them the
trade now
yeah I don't think this is some any any
kind of problem yeah okay I know it
looks we editor to put this on dark
squares but it really it really doesn't
matter why term cannot make any kind of
meaningful progress I can play b5 now
after some preparation and then i have
come to play on the queenside just King
c7 and b5 it's not much that you can do
about it and then I get some play the
bishop on f8 is protecting those two
pawns on g7 he has got no attack on the
g7 porn and c5 is it it's not an active
piece but it fulfills two important
tasks yam now I can try to play against
down the spawn maybe I could play B form
yeah that's not much that he can do can
take on b5 and try to play against c5
but it's not not a big deal this
anticipates a cap Sean be five so that
c5 is double protected cbcb he plays
brooksy once stuff like that and now I
just go to f7 and play g6 trying to
clarify the situation on the King side I
mean it simply cannot cannot do much she
can play em f45 I can go for each 5m
still I don't really see that can can
make any em any
okay i want to mazon check clear this
position check yeah okay and the
question is should I play Bishop c7 okay
let's let's exchange c5 for a 5k simply
didn't and didn't react to that but so
now this Bishop is protecting the F porn
and I've got them got a 5 also so let's
use my own pawns here what didn't think
about this okay but the a porn is Sir
not exactly not exactly bad how does he
stop it not at all yeah I'm just running
now white for fate stay two days
connection now I disconnected him the
poor man's way of resigning as I often
call it yeah of course he should never
lose the same game at somehow he managed
but I don't really think I wasn't any
any kind of specific danger so I'm not
not a big deal alright so I'm very short
on time ever come out and dance need to
get rid of this sound I hope that the
sound of the video has improved and it's
no kind of kind of beeping noise it was
it was so bad yesterday in my recording
but it somehow got even worse after
uploading to youtube so i hope the sound
issue is fixed and yeah like this game
nevertheless it was a quick good game
yeah thanks for watching and talk to you
soon with new stuff